now in the last few minutes hamas's
armed Wing the alasan brigades have
released a statement on their telegram
Channel saying that they have stopped an
Israeli incursion into the Gaza Strip
let's bring in Imran Khan in occupied
East Jerusalem for more on this Imran
what are you hearing about
this well it's worth uh going through
the various statements that have arrived
let's do the kisan brigades who uh
released uh that statement on Telegraph
they are the armed wing of Hamas they
say our mujahadin that's their Fighters
confirm that soldiers of the Zionist
Force that's Israelis uh fell into the
KH Unis Ambush and left their vehicles
and fled east of the ephemeral fence on
foot now the word Ambush there is quite
crucial this may not have been planned
this may well have just happened
spontaneously from the Israeli Army
Palestinian terrorists referring to
Alcan brigades there opened fire at
troops operating on the west western
side of the Gaza board defense NE kavim
the Israeli Army says one of the tanks
shell the cell Hamas earlier claimed to
have clashed with Israeli forces in the
area remember kanun in the south of the
Gaza Strip is supposed to be a safe
place for Palestinians to flee to the
Israelis have made it clear that anybody
within Gaza City is there and it's their
responsibility they are going to go into
Gaza City at some point uh and root out
Hamas and anybody there is simply going
to be part of that routing out by that
they mean fighting they mean shooting so
Han unit was supposed to be a safe place
now we're hearing about clashes uh near
that border fence with hanun that means
Israeli troops certainly confirmed by
the Israeli Army are mounting operations
on that side of the fence and Hamas have
reacted to this this has all happened in
the last few minutes I'll get you more
details as we have them but certainly
the most important thing to note about
this is the fact that KH unes the south
of Gaza is supposed to be a safe
place okay Imran thank you very much for
that update Imran Khan live for us in
occupied East Jerusalem well let's check
in with our correspondent tar Abu AUM
who's live from Gaza now what are you